go today we're trying out something a
bit more extreme we are playing sample
tennis in the middle of this lake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so here begins our building
process here's the raft it's gonna be a
six point seven meters long
yeah it's gonna be a quite a big frost
let's start building so we have four of
these loadings and now we are going to
collect the first two okay and this is
our construction manager Becca he's nice
to meet you too
he's got it all planned out and we trust
that his measurements are correct and
helping helping us here is Patrick is
gonna be the middle part now coming next
oh you guys trying to learn cool so yeah
we have to cool it a bit more to the
lake so we get some more space to build
it over there further further
so this is the length let's go
so this is signal this thing is baby
remember we're gonna take it in the
middle of the starting to look like
something yeah how are you gonna film
from there M is trying to run away we
out here in the middle of a lake
building a raft just so we could get
videos for you so do us a favor and hit
subscribe do it now
okay so we've started building a floor
author and Becca there I think we are
going to run out of food been doing this
for like 15 minutes now I know I'm Anna
it's going to be a new training hall
yeah I'll time training hall so we're
gonna start praying on hearing that in
the middle of the lake I think yeah
we're wrapping things up here we're
gonna continue tomorrow finishing the
raft okay so it's day two of builders
building the rocks there is starting to
look okay let's finish this thing so
we're sort of using whatever we find
how's the grip it's good these sandals
the grip ain't the best I hope I will
not end on the group or a c-section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
check battery
[Music]
it's like crack John Avery everybody's
in the water soon soon soon it's gonna
be coming up right after this and we put
a commercial break here four out of four
yeah
we're drilling the supports onto the
raft so the table won't wobble around so
they look like that
[Music]
is there some people in the middle of
the lake
what are they gonna think like a table
tennis table and a rock in the middle of
lake yeah
it's a final piece of the puzzle yeah
and guys there we go
the raft is ready now take a look at
that it's quite good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
but yeah yeah picking up the balls is so
incredible to be here innit
[Music]
you're good a minute
thank you Oh what about the first person
GoPro playing in the middle of Lake
[Music]
pretty good point I can't wait to play
on this oh ho pretty nice Thanks
oh the landscape is so incredible here
okay no now the raft is actually
underwater yeah we have a bit of a splud
situation
I don't think it's a problem
oh this is how you train footwork on a
summer holiday
[Music]
okay so we're gonna do a pom finiti
diving shot tournament vote on the
comments whose dive was the best so I'm
gonna try to do between the legs he
enters the first one to go ready set go
that wasn't too bad actually it was a
good try ready
[Music]
that was close go
[Music]
again now we will see what the same is
say you can do yeah
okay he wanted to make Oliver the sea
lion it won't take long until of those
picked up okay guys I think it's time to
subscribe and watch my previous episodes
there until next time
[Music]